so let's think about where we've been
this year if you recall back to last
term we actually spent a lot of time on
statistics firstly we did a bit of a
review on descriptive statistics
statistics that allow you to describe a
group or a population these are things
like mean mode and median so our
measures of central tendency or measures
of location is what we also called them
and then you had things like
interquartile range standard deviation
so these are measures of spread and we
had a look at all of these and I hope
that with sort of ringing bells from
previous years when we looked at
statistics and but the important thing
that I want emphasize is and you can see
it here on this graph we're always
looking at a single variables in fact
when we were doing a lot of these
calculations on your calculator we would
go into the stats mode and then we would
select one var do you remember that and
one var of course stands for one
variable in this case it's temperature
and that you can see over there in the
horizontal axis and we often have a
vertical axis too but when you're
looking at a single variable the
vertical axis is pretty much always as
you can see in this example frequency
like how many things of those particular
values do you have do you have many days
at 20 degrees or you know do you have
just a couple at 18 degrees as an
example right so when we lose from
single variable statistics add another
variable
you might recall this is called yep it's
bivariate data right so here you can see
again it's a 2-dimensional chart but
it's it's quite different because the
vertical axis here represents a whole
other data point right so here we're
comparing two quantities that are
clearly related and the number of
customers who walk into a store and the
amount that you actually make in sales
based on that number of customers okay
so bivariate data because this was newer
to us and we were going to explore it a
lot more depth this is where we
introduced a bunch of new concepts so
just to sort of refresh your memory a
little bit I wonder if when you guys
look at these charts here if you can
remember what's this referring to what's
what's different across these different
images and it's this idea of correlation
do you remember that you've got two
variables like like say sales and number
of customers and they can be very
closely coral
like if you know the number of customers
who walked in that enables you to very
accurately predict how much was made in
sales at the shop during the day and
that would be what we call a positive
correlation and some of the correlations
are high other ones are low it's like I
don't know they're roughly vaguely in
the same area but sometimes there is no
correlation right it's kind of like your
let me give you an example you know the
the the temperature in the day might
have zero effect on you know how many
sales you have if the thing that you're
selling doesn't have to do with hot or
cold like it was ice creams that would
matter if it was something like a car
maybe you wouldn't matter right so
sometimes there is no connection no
correlation and also as you can see on
the charts correlation can run in two
different directions it can be positive
which means that as you increase one the
other one also increases or it can be
negative when you get more of one you
get less of the other so I think if you
recall back to not the most recent tasks
you did buy the one before that which
had statistics in it I think we gave you
an example scenario where you've got a
school and the exam marks of students so
the two variables the bivariate part of
it was English marks and Max marks and
as an example this obviously doesn't
have to be the case but in this
particular dataset there was a negative
correlation students who did better in
English tended to do poorer in
mathematics and vice-versa now it's not
always the case but perhaps there was
something going on with this school that
accounted for that and that's what we
call a negative correlation now one of
the things that we noticed was well we
want to be able to quantify what's going
on like these words like high and low
sometimes we saw words like moderate
they're all a bit vague and flaky like
one person's high might not be the same
as another person's high and so you're
like well what do you actually mean so
what we did was we introduced a
numerical way to describe correlation
and I wonder if and if you remember what
it was called and her special name we
call it yeah Pearson's coefficient so
this is the number which you know it
maxed out at 1 that means that you know
they're perfectly positively correlated
it went to zero which means it's like no
connection between the two variables and
then also we saw negative
correlation which means you've got a
negative Pearson's coefficient right now
these are not the only things we
explored in bivariate data I wonder if
you remembered we took plots of um you
know information like this and then we
would draw something through it much
like if it's now I wonder how many of
you remember what this is called it's a
line of best fit yes you can also call
the trend line if you want to be very
fancy you can call it a regression line
all of them mean the same thing it's a
line that kind of fits what most of the
data looks like it gives you a sense to
you know what's the general shape of
this thing is going up is it going down
and what that line of best fit or the
trendline lets you do is you know sort
of guess at where you have gaps in your
data so do you guys recall what's it
like when you try and make a prediction
and that's some unknown data point but
as you can see for this one it's within
your data set yeah this one's called
interpolation cuz it's in the data set
whereas if I gave you a point out here
and said well my line of best fit
predicts that if you had you know 11
customers this is what would happen I
don't actually have a data point there
so and this is outside of our data set
and that's why we call it do remember
extrapolation ok so that's all really
helpful I just hope that sort of jogs
your memory I'm the important thing that
I want to get across to you which is our
bridge into today's new content is that
everything we looked at in bivariate
data closely anyway everything we really
investigated was what we call a discrete
random variable ok now I heard that that
phrase is sort of somewhere kicking
around in your brain but let me don't
remember what it means a variable of
course refers to the fact that you've
got quantities that change like sales
numbers they go up and they go down
random means there is some kind of sense
that each different thing is equally
likely each different outcome I mean
this word discrete this is the one I
really want to focus on discrete means
you've got separate values um distinct
values is a way that I used to remember
it discreet means distinct sales they're
in dollars and you count them out right
it's like a specific number of dollars
and the customers is the same like you
can't have ten and a half customers you
either have ten or you have eleven and
so wherever you've got value
where they take on specific numbers and
they can't go in between this is what we
call a discrete random variable now some
of you will recall right at the
beginning of statistics we kind of wave
this flag but then we didn't really
touch it we did say that there's other
kinds of data bits not to screen there
is what we call a continuous random
variable and whole idea here is that you
don't have specific numbers and you
can't go in between the whole idea is
that you have a continuum of values and
these I'm really excited about learning
these things properly we do this is what
we're going to dive into for the next
couple of weeks because number one they
are they're everywhere and they're
really important to understand and
number two and the tools that you use to
understand this have some really
fantastic connections to other knowledge
that we've developed as you'll see
shortly I'm sort of getting ahead of
myself okay so let's think about
continuous random variables why do we
care about them let me do some examples
okay number one a lot of the data that
we actually encounter like I mentioned
before it doesn't fit into nice neat
categories so any time basically you
measure something rather than counter it
if you measure say a temperature right
your thermometer might say 37 degrees
but it might take 37 point one might say
37 point zero five like it kind of
you're only limited by the accuracy of
your instrument so it is there's a
continuum there right so if you've got
continuous data then you would use
continuous random variables to represent
that but here's the kicker right even
when you've got a discrete set of data
discrete distribution even that
sometimes can be helpfully understood
using a continuous model so here's an
example for you okay if you took 20
coins and just sort of spilled them out
onto the table and then you counted how
many were heads and how many were tails
right and then you repeated that
experiment over and over again then you
would get data that looks something like
this you're looking at a plot that gives
you the the relative frequency you can
see the vertical axis it's P of x equals
extra that's a probability right so
however many number of experiments you
do divide by that number of experiments
how many times did you get seven heads
out of 20 how many times did you get 11
20 okay now when you have a look at this
data which I want to remind you it comes
from a discrete situation so you can't
have you know one and a half you know
tails or something like that you're
going to have one or two even though
this is discrete data I hope you can see
the shape of the data itself kind of
implies that this sort of a curve
underneath this right and this is
because the data set is sufficiently
large that's sort of you know you've got
this behavior around it that is not
doesn't look discrete actually looks
continuous and that's what you can do
here I actually went into desmos and I
had a bit of a fiddle and I came up with
an equation that very very closely
matches the data that's been presented
so I know this equation looks messy but
the point is it's a continuous model
that fits discrete data okay and so
number one your discrete data can
sometimes look like continuous data when
you have enough of it and the other
thing which is sort of a secret
superpower that continuous models have
is it then enable you if you you know
extrapolate better to make predictions
about what's going on right so let's
have a look at this set of data here do
you remember having a look at this idea
of a logistic model which is a
continuous model that we use to
represent a discrete situation like this
is the number of cases of covert 19 in a
particular scene you can't have 500 and
a half people who have been diagnosed
with co19 uij they're 500 or 501 and
despite being a discrete situation a
continuous model is useful because it
enable us to make predictions about the
future and that's kind of a big deal
right like policy decisions when do we
reopen our economies when are we allowed
to have sport again when are we allowed
to you know eat into restaurants again
rather than have all the delivery all
these things are very practical
questions that depend on continuous
models